cette émission on vous propose vous
propose chaque jour de débat vous l'avez
compris le premier il est directement
liée à l'actualité le second il est un
peu plus prospectif chaque jour on va
choisir un thème pour l'analyser en
profondeur alors ça pourrait être un
droit de suite on va revenir sur un
événement passé pour voilà prendre le
temps de le comprendre ou alors on va
essayer de
faire un peu de prospective et justement
c'est de l'avenir de marine le pen que
l'on va parler tout de suite elle se
lance dans sa troisième campagne
présidentielle et si c'était celle de
trop et si marine le pen était has been
avant de débattre de cette question qui
va sûrement faire réagir sur le hashtag
séance publique notre reportage ce
week-end à fréjus la présidente du
rassemblement national transmettait le
flambeau à jordan bardella les militants
se voulait confiant malgré la menace
fantôme d'eric zemmour fabien becker
marie brémaud
pour marine le pen il était urgent de
remobiliser ses troupes nouvelle affiche
de campagne et météo au beau fixe à
fréjus les élus et rennes se veulent
optimistes
peu importe la défaite de 2017 ou les
récents échecs aux élections locales eux
croient toujours en leur candidate pour
2022 quand on voit que toutes les idées
de marine le pen sans reprise maintenant
parler parler l air par exemple
sincèrement ça veut dire que c'est le
bon chemin depuis longtemps et qu'elle a
toutes ses chances d'être élue cette
année tu penses que c'est la candidate
souverainiste digitimes donc je pense
que quelque part oui faut qu elle il
faut que les souverainistes arrive au
pouvoir
un camp souverainiste pourtant draguer
par eric zemmour la possible candidature
du polémiste déstabiliser certains
militants actuellement ça
ça serait parti sur un
bloc mais l'état major du parti sera sûr
en regardant les sondages qui donnent
pour l'instant marine le pen au second
tour officiellement eric zemmour n'est
pas un sujet aux arènes le considère pas
comme un adversaire il est un concurrent
parmi d'autres et voilà notre adversaire
c'est évidemment monsieur macron et pour
installer le match avec emmanuel macron
marine le pen se posent en défenseurs
des libertés qu'elle voit menacée très
applaudie dans sa critique du passé ni
terre avant de galvaniser sa base quand
elle aborde l'identité et la sécurité
france les français ont le droit de
vivre comme des procès
les délinquants seront donc mis hors
d'état de nuire les délinquants français
en prison les étrangers dans l'avion
un discours très classique de la
candidate pour rassurer ses troupes et
lancer sa campagne devant les militants
jordan bardella a été intronisé nouveau
président du rassemblement national
marine le pen elle veut désormais être
la présidente des français marine le pen
était là has been c'est le thème de
notre débat je vous présente mes invités
iris boyer bonjour bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes chercheuse en sciences
politiques secrétaire général de la
branche française de l'institut pour le
dialogue stratégique à vos côtés charles
sapin bonjour bonjour journaliste au
figaro vous suivi le rassemblement
national vous étiez à fréjus ce week-end
vous venez de réaliser l'interview de
rentrer en quelque sorte de marine le
pen pour pour le figaro et vous publiez
macron le pen le temps mots des
fossoyeurs c'est aux éditions de
l'archipel jean yves camus bonjour
bienvenue roue de vous accueillir vous
êtes politologue que directeur de
l'observatoire des radicalités politique
à la fondation jean jaurès spécialistes
les droits d extrême droite vous avez
publié avec nicolas lebourg les droites
extrêmes en europe c'était c'est au
seuil que ce livre a été publié matthieu
croissandeau éditorialistes est toujours
à mes côtés et puis on on sera si tout
va bien tout à l'heure en
visioconférence avec robert ménard le
maire de béziers qui publie notamment
cher mari de ce qu'elle doit faire pour
gagner on lui poserait directement la
question est elle ou non has been et et
je démarre avec ça en fait je fais un
premier tour de table avec cette idée
qu'est ce que vous répondez jean yves
camus france avec vous moi je réponds
les sondages actuellement
donne un match macron le pen au second
tour de manière constante y compris
lorsque hypothèse eric zemmour et tester
alors dans des proportions qui changent
24% au coude à coude dans certains cas
19% pour marine le pen c'est important
parce que c'est en dessous du seuil un
peu psychologique des 20 % mais la
configuration de second tour je pense
qu'elle restera la même donc ce sera
peut-être le dernier second tour à se
présenter ainsi
après c'est savoir si marine le pen ont
rompu leurs amarres mais je crois que
c'est parti pour durer donc votre
réponse c'est plutôt non si j'ai bien
compris as qu'elle ait ali bin ouais bon
la réponse est nourrice boyer qu'est ce
que vous répondez à cette question je
pense que c'est une question très
binaire mais effectivement je rejoins
jean yves camus sur les sondages mais
qu'il faut mettre à mon avis en
parallèle avec les observations qu'on
peut faire sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur les réseaux sociaux on voit bien qu
en tout cas dans les dernières semaines
et notamment avant avant son interview
d'hier soir qui a vraiment marqué le
début de campagne pour elle la
mobilisation était un peu dur mais on va
dire surtout quand on la met en
parallèle avec par exemple celle d'eric
zemmour qui a qui a quasiment doublé son
niveau d'interaction sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est bon on peut dire qu'elle
était elle était un peu dormantes à ce
niveau là mais encore une fois il faut
le mettre en parallèle avec avec les
statistiques et les sondages et je pense
qu'elle se porte elle se pose plutôt en
présidentiable quand d'autres personnes
peuvent faire peuvent jouer le rôle de
saturation de l'espace médiatique et de
pousser ses idées par d'autres canaux
notamment les réseaux sociaux charles
sapa est-ce que marine le pen est has
been je me permet de déplacer un peu la
question c'est qui n'est pas has been si
on regarde de près
l'échiquier politique à la veille de
cette présidentielle c'est la dernière
campagne présidentielle très
certainement quasi certainement de
marine le pen c'est la dernière
présidentielle de jean-louis affirmatif
c'est certainement la campagne
l'assumera à ne l'assument aura pas
comme tel en campagne c'est très très
difficile de dire c'est ma dernière
campagne présidentielle et son entourage
ses plus proches le répète la logique
ces trois campagnes
là si vous voulez si elle échoue une
troisième fois
laissé son entourage c'est du lieutenant
feront que ils mettront en place un
renouvellement mais s'ils ont des zooms
un petit peu vous regarder je vous
attendent parce que cette démonstration
on y viendra un peu plus tard dans le
débat j'ai plutôt faire appel à votre à
votre ressenti du de fréjus est ce que
cette question elle était un peu dans
l'air du temps c'est là où cette crainte
forcément d'être voilà d'être un peu
dépassé il faisait mourir et c'est à
partir du moment où on est dans un dans
une dans un meeting dans un week end où
l'un des moments fort a été le passage
de témoin ça fait dix ans que marine le
pen à la tête du rassemblement national
à partir du moment où un jeune
lieutenant qu'elle a elle-même montée
qui allait enfin qu'elle a présenté
comme son dauphin de 26 ans prend les
rênes d'un parti non pas pour deux
semaines comme c'était le cas lors de la
dernière présidentielle marine le pen
s'était mis en retrait entre 1 et 2
tours bon c'était très court là on voit
là et on en a pour 7 mois donc il va
devoir prendre des décisions difficiles
dit il va devoir se placer au niveau de
l'actualité il va forcément en tant que
chef devoir faire entendre sa propre
petite musique ce qu'on n'a pas vraiment
entendu depuis les européennes où il a
vraiment éclos dans l'espace public
c'est une question qui était très
présente
évidemment tout le monde s'interdit de
de répondre à cette question d'entourage
de marine le pen j'ai posé la question à
jordan bardet les médias attendent et je
ne me projette la réponse était je ne me
projette pas après la victoire de marine
le pen alors on va poser la même
question je vous donnerai la parole
après mathieu à robert ménard qui est
avec nous en direct le maire de béziers
en visioconférence bonjour robert ménard
je rappelle qu'un commissaire marine ce
qu'elle doit faire pour gagner aux
éditions la nouvelle librairie je sais
pas si vous allez répondre directement à
ma question mais est ce que vous vous
êtes vous aussi peut-être tient juste
après le le débat delà de la
présidentielle précédente ou ou de temps
en temps ces dernières semaines est ce
que vous vous ai demandé si marine le
pen était has been
j'ai reçu demande évidemment et le débat
du deux tours si elle pourrait jeu se
relever de de ce mauvais débat de ce
mauvais épisode et scharner douter jeu
gouvy méchaal élevés lit d'où la
brouille qui a été la nôtre pendant
pendant un bon moment j'ai le sentiment
que depuis quelques mois et elle prend
elle fuit les leçons de ses échecs
italien intéressante que l'amour ça veut
dire qu'elle est en train de tourner la
page ça tombe d'affirmation du
rassemblement national qui ne sont pas
réalistes il lui reste du chemin à faire
je vous le conseille sur le terrain
économique et social elle est une chaîne
espère en train de prendre ses distances
avec avec son propre parti chez lui je
lui dis marine il faut absolument te
départir des gens en santé compagnon de
route de depuis des années qu'ils se
tiennent chaud au coeur parce que c'est
pas facile mais dans son rôle mais en
même temps que tu as dont tu as besoin
de te de te séparer pourquoi prendre une
autre dimension et ensuite il faut
qu'elle change puisque les siennes lui
mais c'est tout ce que j'écris j'ai bien
évidemment vous en doutez de vie bois
avant je les lis au rond avec les
pratiques complice cullers de ton parti
stade il faut traiter les autres
dignement il faut signer des compromis
pour faire des compromis et surtout il
faut rassurer rassurer rassuré par
semaine et faire le contraire de ce que
te pousse ce à quoi tu penses une partie
des gens autour de toi la famille ne te
radicaliser c'est pas le moment
aujourd'hui les jambes ils sont d'accord
génération 70 % à penser qu'ils sont
d'accord une telle et telle de nos
propositions sur l'immigration la
sécurité l'école ou que sais-je encore
et après ils hésitent à voter pour nous
donc pu tâter roja dessus pourquoi tu
nous continuons à faire peur volage que
ce que j'espère ce que je lui dis et
pour répondre à votre question oui j'ai
pensé qu'à un moment donné elle aurait
dû se retirer michel impressionné tant
qu' elle est quand même en position en
empire l'année dans la meilleure
position quant à gagner nos idées mais
c'est loin d'être créée je ne concède
largement rester avec nous robert ménard
je vais évidemment vous vous faire
réagir dans un court instant je voudrais
jean yves camus savoir ce que vous
réagissiez aux propos de robert ménard à
l'instant serre que yahia quoi il ya
vraiment deux deux rassemblements
nationale qui continue de s'opposer deux
stratégies différentes et la cua un peu
de mal à choisir peut-être marine le pen
ou alors elle a tranché non marine le
pen je crois est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement fidèle en amitié y compris
avec un certain nombre de gens qui l'ont
soutenu au moment
difficile et elle a du mal sans doute à
se départir selon tant que vous venez
d'utiliser d'un certain nombre de liens
avec des gens qui pour être des amis ne
sont pas nécessairement de bons
conseillers politiques mais elle a fait
et l'ajout rejoint monsieur le maire
elle a fait du chemin sur la crédibilité
moi je retiens notamment le texte
qu'elle a donnée au quotidien le monde
vous savez dans cet exercice
qui consiste à à disséquer le livre de
pierre rosanvallon et outre le fait que
ce texte était bien écrit qu'il était
nettement au dessus en terme de niveau
de ceux qui l'avaient précédé il
ressemblait à une porte entrouverte vers
un dialogue comme dans un certain nombre
de pays je pense en particulier à
l'italie il est courant il est normal de
dialoguer avec ses adversaires
politiques y compris à l'autre bout du
spectre politique en respectant un
certain nombre de règles basiques du jeu
mais ce texte qui comportait un certain
nombre de thèmes extrêmement intéressant
je pense notamment à la phrase que
marine le pen écrivait sur le fait qu'il
n'y avait encore une partie de la
population française qui était être
attaché aux idéologies je crois qu'elle
a raison là dans la fin du texte ce seul
mot important qui était le mot
d'optimisme
optimisme c'est à dire il ya
effectivement les constat que fait
marine le pen qui sont des constats
sévères voire dramatique mais en même
temps et je crois contrairement à eric
zemmour elle évite de sombrer dans un
catastrophisme qui peut s'avérer
incapacitant pour celui qui le qu'il
propose parce que certains moments quand
vous êtes dans votre canapé et que vous
regardez quelqu'un qui vous dit legrand
placement c'est déjà fait tout est fichu
il est minuit moins cinq vous vous dites
ok
l'essentiel c'est que je passe à travers
et puis le reste on verra et une
élection ça se gagne aussi sur sur
l'espoir est ce que est ce qu'on peut
réussir à générer
sur les électeurs robert ménard cc c'est
passionnant qui vient de dire jean yves
camus le l'optimisme est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous essayer
d'insuffler à marine le pen quand vous
discutez avec elle moi je suis d'accord
absolument il ya un avis ils font une
droite de droite mais une droite
bienveillante bienveillant qui les rend
très sévère sur les questions
d'immigration par exemple et sur les
immigrés comprendre un certain nombre de
choses on peut se dire que il ya tout un
tas de gens qui abusent du droit
dellerie etc l'obtiennent pas d'ailleurs
se rappelle que les deux tiers aux gens
maison tient pas mais le tiers qui
n'obtiennent il faut être généreux avec
eux la grandeur de ce pays l'ont signé
de monsieur ce qui manque à nos droits
on a une droite qui pensent que toujours
été que tout était mieux avant mais
c'est pas vrai que tout était mieux
avant du coup ça donne une droite qui
regardait une partie de l'est de
l'extrême droite qui va manifester dans
la rue contre le pattani terre on
al'impression d'obscurs antilles alors
que je sais pas moi je suis à droite
deux raisons une droite raisonnable une
droite qui a envie de donner de l'espoir
aux gens peut pas simplement leur dire
tout va mal moi je suis ravi qu'un
certain nombre de cours et oui il ya des
progrès le progrès ça n'appartient pas à
à monsieur mâcon et je pense qu'il ya
toute une révolution a à faire en gros
il faut sortir du lepénisme sortir de
l'eau bénite qu'elle s'appelle le pen
est ce c'est la énième convoquant pagne
dans le pen quand même ce soit quand des
sites au problème ça fait 5 campagne de
jean et le pen c'est la troisième
campagne de marine le pen en fait une
candidature la présentielle ces trois
choses c'est d'abord une offre politique
est ce que le projet de marine le pen
tel qu'il est présenté aujourd'hui est
ringard s qui est has been n'en pense ce
qu'on veut on est pour on est content
mais elle a plutôt travaillé son projet
elle a plutôt fait son aggiornamento là
plutôt moderniser ensuite il ya une
question d' espace politique est-ce que
sur l'espace politique sur lequel est
ancrée marine le pen et une concurrence
qui serait plus berne quelque hilarant
verrait un côté has been et là je vous
rejoins le concurrent qui émergent eric
zemmour c'est lui la conservation c'est
lui le temps d'avancé lui d'une certaine
façon qui est bine dans ses idées ses
pelles après il ya une équation
personnelle marine le pen est là on
vient sur votre question le nom de le
pen 5 campagne de jean-marie le pen
trois campagnes de marine le pen est ce
qu'au bout d'un moment les français
n'ont pas un ras-le-bol de voir un le
pen à une élection présidentielle
d'autant que la personnalité de marine
le pen et là on peut se poser la
question pas forcément d'être has been
ou pas mais est-ce qu'elle a progressé
est ce qu elle a tiré les leçons d'un
point de vue personnel de sa défaite la
réponse la question reste entière en
tout cas mes yeux robert ménard votre
point de vue là-dessus la la campagne de
l'ouganda le pen
non je pense qu'il faut évidemment mais
je lui glisse dans son petit livre il
faut que ce soit la dernière campagne
qu'elle lâche le parti complètement il
faut qu'elles aient toutes les forces
pour me regarder j'y crois tellement que
je prend tous les risques fait at war
conjugent de la force d'un politique
c'est à dire qu'ils prennent le maximum
de risques il faut qu'elle le fera je
pense qu'elle est avec elle est en train
de changer écoutez moi je la connais
assez bien je la fréquente depuis des
années même si jamais j'ai jamais
inquiet dans son parti on a eu des
moments de rapports très très difficile
il me semble qu'elle a compris ou trois
choses à kadoma gagner tout seul que son
parti ne peut pas gagner tout seul et
que c'est par où six ans comme ça que le
rn va gagner mais qui pousse qui s'allie
à perdre des gens la deuxième chose
c'est que les alliances chez pas la
succession on peut pas demander aux gens
des 26 on leur donne on leur demande des
partenaires des les partenaires il ça
veut dire les respecter ensuite la
troisième chose il me semble qu est qu
elle a compris c'est que aujourd'hui
comme comment vous dire si on veut
gagner si on veut gagner il faut faire
des compromis des compromis elle n'y
était pas prêt à n'y était pas vraiment
je vous rappelle les dix missions avant
le premier tour de l'élection dernière
elles n'étaient pas prêts à des
compromis le savez la droite ou la
droite experts extrême elle a fait une
thèse de tentation de la turcité je
connais quelque chose parce que moi je
viens de l'extrême-gauche déjà vu
exactement les mêmes c'est à dire il
faut toujours être plus radicale plus
sorte au dos plus jusqu'au boutiste que
votre voisin à côté voilà ce que je
regrette et je finis à l'abc si vous
permettez pas ce qui signifie une
réunion du conseil municipal
c'est juste dire moi je pensais que la
candidature de d'eric zemmour dans la
pratique moi je veux gagner moi je suis
pas nous arrêter je suis un militant
cette affaire là que ibm où devait se
situer entre marine le pen et les
républicains pourtant une espèce de
passerelles ce que je devrais je sais
plus qui qu'il a dit l'interlocuteur
juste avant ce que j'ai besoin qu'il ne
s'éclipse se situe à droite de marine le
pen et que c'est peut-être une erreur de
positionnement pour lui merci robert
ménard chère marine ce qu'elle doit
faire pour gagner aux éditions la
nouvelle librairie bonne bonne session
bonne réunion conseil
municipal on va tient justement écouter
marine le pen sur ce qu'elle dit d'eric
zemmour c'était hier soir dans le
journal de tf1 je n'ai encore une fois
pas d'adversaire dans le camp de ceux
qui croient en la france donc ça c'est
un grand clivage ceux qui croient en la
france et ceux qui n'y croient plus je
pense que eric zemmour fait partie de
ceux qui croient en la france nous avons
des divergences c'est sûr je pense qu'on
gagne dans l'union et pas dans la
division donc je ne le traiterait jamais
comme un adversaire
on peut prendre ça comme un appel du
pied vous voyez oui je le vois comme ça
que ça soit directement ou indirectement
je pense que quand on parle beaucoup
d'eric zemmour troublion ou trouble fête
mais mais quelque part on peut aussi
voir eric zemmour comme un faire-valoir
ou quelqu'un qui a préparé le terrain où
quelqu'un qui va parler à d'autres
audiences et les mobiliser de manière
différente en accentuant sur les
polémiques en faisant le buzz en donnant
aussi une impression qui a peut être une
plus grosse communauté une communauté
plus constitué de soutien derrière et
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux et je
pense que ça
ça ça peut finalement même pourquoi pas
aider
l'agenda
politique de marine le pen et sa volonté
de c'est à dire quand même temps
qu'elles qu'elles qu'elles jouent sur la
normalisation l'aspect présidentiable
quelqu'un d'autre entre guillemets fait
le travail et se pose comme le chantre
légitime de la mise à l'agenda des idées
identitaires depuis des années et alors
quoi pourrait lui servir de réservoir de
voix pour un second tour éventuellement
au vide c'est ce que je rentre pas de
caisse de résonance et et ça contribue à
la normalisation à la normalisation de
ses idées on a même vu après juste
certes un certain soutien appelé de
leurs voeux
voilà ce cette mobilisation autour
d'eric zemmour et dire finalement plutôt
que de diviser le camp national au final
ça pousse aussi ça pousse aussi nos
idées donc tout ce qui contribue aux 7
pouces et des idées peut-être que ça
donnera lieu à une coalition à la fin
charles sapin eric zemmour trop à droite
finalement ou à l'extrême droite disait
robert ménard tout à l'heure
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse
en fait c'est ce qui est interdit et sur
20 ans je vais au bout de la question
parce qu on est sur un débat marine le
pen et sur ce que ça provoque en
conséquence pour les chances de victoire
du marine le pen première chose moi j'ai
du mal à classer les xénons enfin on
connaît tous ces constats crépusculaire
bon moi j'attends un programme en fait
donc à partir du moment où monsieur
zemmour n'a pas pris position sur les
minimas sociaux sur les retraites sur
quelles mesures ils proposent sur
l'immigration de ce pour l'instant il
comprend que vous l'avez très bien dit
tout à l'heure on sait 23h55
finalement on va mourir d'une subversion
mais mais qu'est ce qu'ils proposent
tant qu'il n'y a pas de proposition sur
la table c'est très difficile en tant
qu'observateur de de le classer
gg rebondir sur ce que vous dites c'est
intéressant le seul problème c'est que
là où eric zemmour n'est pas forcément
une aide pour marine le pen c'est qu'il
ne fait pas justement des attaques sur
le programme de marine le pen mais il
faut il fait des attaques personnelles
il dit en gros qu'elle est incompétente
qu'elle est incapable de gagner et que
tout le monde le sait ce qui est
intéressant c'est pourquoi la réciproque
n'est pas vraie pourquoi marine le pen
n'attaque pas eric zemmour c'est parce
que au lendemain de l'élection de 2017
l comme emmanuel macron d'ailleurs on
fait un même constat c'est que pour se
maintenir voire pour survivre à moyen
terme il fallait se débarrasser de ce
vieux clivages qui est le clivage droite
gauche et % et pour le s'en débarrasser
pour le dépasser il fallait y substituer
un nouveau clivage alors ce nouveau
clivage lit pas totalement fixé mais il
a plusieurs noms un z et les
eurosceptiques européen les
nationalistes les mondialistes ce que
marie marine le pen caricature un petit
peu dans cet entretien que vous avez
cités elle dit ceux qui croient en la
france et ceux qui n'y croient plus
history
en fait dans son récit pour justement
imposer ce nouveau clivage ont pas de
deux avec emmanuel macron on en
reparlera peut-être il se trouve que
eric zemmour et de son côté du clivage
de qu'elle ne peut pas attaquer
quelqu'un qui quelle voix dans son camp
elle ne va pas créer une ligne de
clivage ce qui finalement affaiblir et
là la seule ligne de clivage qui vaille
et qui peut l'amener selon elle au
second tour face à mma qu'on utilise ce
cette ligne de clivage qui oppose de
chef de l'état je voudrais revenir sur
ce que le slogan de campagne qu'on a
qu'on a vu hier enfin ce week-end à
fréjus le le temps est venu c'est quand
même assez frappant comme comme
formulation jean yves camus c'est
presque messianique quand vous
l'analysez ce slogan je ne sais pas si
marine le pen à méditer l'évangile de
marc agents de
choisir ce slogan mais il est exact dans
l'évangile selon saint marc c'est une
expression que l'on trouve dans un
contexte très particulier
qui est celui de la prédication de jésus
en guinée qui dit marc 1,15
le royaume de dieu est proche
il faut que vous acceptiez la bonne
nouvelle
ça veut dire aussi on est à la croisée
des chemins on est au moment où chacun
doit se déterminer je crois qu'elle l'a
formulé comme ça c'est clairement
d'ailleurs et où c'est un peu la
dernière occasion d'y arriver
voilà je ne dis pas c'est pas qui a été
le porte plume de ce passage du discours
peut-être que c'est un un catholique qui
connaissent les écritures mais c'est
vrai que si on enlève la référence
religieuse il ya quand même le fait que
voilà c'est maintenant que ça joue
peut-être parce qu'il y aura pas
précisément de quatrième candidature tu
faisais lorsque l'état du pays selon
elle est trop délabré pour qu'ensuite on
puisse remonter la pente alors on
reprend la thématique est pourquoi je
vous ai interrompu tout ça va parce que
tous savent bin c'est un peu ce que vous
voulez nour a brûlé matthieu
croissandeau charles caisse 15 buts en
politique est ce que c'est un sentiment
de déjà-vu et si si c'est un sentiment
de déjà vu à ce compte là marine le pen
est loin d'être seul prenez jean luc
mélenchon 70 ans troisième campagne il a
démarré sa carrière politique en 1983 à
l'époque du tournant de la rigueur c'est
dire et enfin je peux le faire du tout
le procès de son âge mais voilà il se
représente avec quasiment le même
programme donc pour du déjà vu
c'est du déjà vu emmanuel macron trop
jeune pour être has been peut-être mais
lui aussi a maintes fois se réinventer
quand on regarde un on est quatre ans
après son élection sait toujours pas ce
que c'est que le maquereau nice mais les
rues aime toujours pas avancé sur ce
point on sait que c'est en gros une star
style de pouvoir certaines exercice du
pouvoir trop autoritaire dise les uns
avec une volonté de réforme mais quelles
réformes pour 2022 quoi de neuf alors là
rien sont vraiment nouveau sous le
soleil si on nous sort quoi la réforme
des retraites précisément celle qui
figurait dans le programme de 2017 et
qu'il n'a pas pu mettre en place à
l'encontre des formations politiques qui
ne change les programmes des deux
candidats on pourrait ajouter philippe
poutou nathalie arthaud nicolas dupont
aignan bref ça fait près d'un tiers de
l'offre politique mais l'essentiel des
nouveaux candidats oui ça il ya des
nouveaux mais on peut être nouveaux et
puis anciens dans sa tête prenait xavier
bertrand par exemple une décennie clip
ans 4 ans qui se prépare un think tank
des réseaux tout ça pour quoi pour nous
vendre un triptyque autorités
travaillent territoire la belle affaire
c'est la base dont on est de droite
avant que rien quand on dit je suis pour
l'autorité je suis pour la valeur
travail et je suis pour les territoires
on dirait du sarkozy en 2007 et encore
on est sympa al hilal go de son côté
elle vient de se lancer à réparer vinel
mais quand on l'écouté hier j'avais
parfois l'impression d'assister à un
vieux congrès du parti socialiste tout y
était allé clin d'oeil aux
fonctionnaires aux enseignants en tête à
la cité jaurès blum mendès mitterrand
elle veut bâtir une france plus juste
tiens vous savez qui a utilisé ce slogan
présider autrement une france plus juste
c'était lionel jospin en 2002 enfants ça
lui a pas porté chance qu'est-ce que ça
traduit ça traduit avant un premier truc
à mon avis c'est une absence de travail
et d'imagination de la part de ces
candidats c'est plus facile de piocher
dans les vieilles recettes se sont
pourtant pas les nouveaux défis qui
manque un je vous en donne un la
révolution numérique comme on en pagne
comment la compagne comment l'encadrer
il ya on n'entend absolument rien là
dessus et puis je vous parle pas de la
pandémie qui pour le coup
y a pas non plus de débat la seconde
raison de fond celle là c'est que c'est
difficile de se réinventer en politique
faut le dire et puis que la nouveauté ça
garantit pas forcément le succès prenez
le revenu universel de benoît hamon tout
le monde rit caennais ya quatre ans tout
le monde en parle dans tous les partis
aujourd'hui et lui benoît hamon a
carrément jeté l'épongé en se retirant
de vue politique et puis vous savez il
ya des has been qui réussissent à
renverser la table ça s'est déjà vu par
le passé mitterrand 81 chirac en 95 deux
candidats ringard à leur époque devenu
président au nez à la barbe de tous ceux
qui veulent enterrer trop vite charles
sapin est ce qu'il ya est-ce qu'il ya la
place où est-ce que c'est trop tard pour
un candidat surprise où il ya toujours
et place fin c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que enfin nous sommes tous passionnés de
politique sait que c'est c'est riche en
surprises jusqu'à la dernière seconde
après
ce qui est intéressant de voir dans
cette dans cette élection c'est que
c'est quasiment inédit faim depuis 2010
est il n'y a pas un seul sondage c'est
systématique qui donne emmanuel
maintenant où marine le pen en tête
alors même que 70 % des français ne
veulent pas la reddition de ce duel et
si vous voulez c'est un peu la question
qui nous a qui nous a intéressés quand
on sait quand on s'est lancé dans ce
projet de livre le tango des fossoyeurs
avait que mon confrère du figaro
françois xavier bonbons on a essayé de
comprendre ce paradoxe et on a on a vu
donc ce ce constat partagé des manuels
mcqueen marine le pen qui pour survivre
ont décidé de 2,2 si vous voulez de
faire un coup de balai sur ce clivage
droite gauche et pour instaurer un
nouveau clivage tout à leur avantage
sont rentrés dans un pas de deux où ils
se sont adaptés l'un à l'autre dans tous
les grands moments du quinquennat vous
prenez les gilet jaune vous prenez le
coup vite vous prenez la loi séparatisme
à chaque fois ils sont rentrés dans une
relation d'opposition exclusive pour
devenir le négatif parfait de l'un de
l'autre ce qui a eu pour effet
d'asphyxier totalement les autres forces
politiques et voilà on en arrive de
quatre ans après à une situation où ils
sont toujours en tête et souvent les
gens disent non mais s'il n'y a pas de
candidat de droite naturel s'il n'y a
pas de candidat de gauche naturel c'est
parce qu'ils sont tous chenu
c'est ce qu' il ya une génération qui a
été balayée celle qui est en dessous
mais est en fait c'est parce que c'est
nous qu'on notre si vous voulez notre
théorie ce qu'on défend c'est que en
regardant toute l'histoire du coriace et
ii du quinquennat c'est que n'y a pas eu
d' espace politique pour qu'un autre
une autre force politique un autre si
vous voulez puisse sortir on se on se
souvient du candidat de droite aux
européennes françois xavier bellamy
n'était sondés à 13 14 15 et finalement
ce jeu marine le pen emmanuel macron
voté contre macron pour le rn voter pour
la liste la république en marche et le
seul rempart contre la lèpre populiste
de l'autre côté le candidat qui devait
faire renaître la droite il est tombé à
8 donc votre question est ce qu'il peut
y avoir un trublion oui est ce que c'est
le scénario favori non marine le pen
combien de divisions on a voulu répondre
à cette question marion vigreux va nous
rejoindre de nouveau dans cette dans ce
sens public pour regarder dans le
rétroviseur
marion vous pouvez faire le point sur
l'implantation du rassemblement national
finalement depuis la dernière
présidentielle effectivement avec cette
question le rassemblement national at-il
en cinq ans étendu son influence sur le
territoire gagné ou perdu des électeurs
depuis l élection présidentielle les
français ont été appelés quatre fois aux
urnes en juin 2010 est tout d'abord pour
les élections législatives qui désigne
les députés le front national fait alors
rentrer huit députés à l'assemblée
nationale
c'est 6 de plus par rapport à 2012 en
2019 les français sont cette fois-ci
invités à désigner leurs députés
européens le front national devenu
rassemblement national arrive en tête du
scrutin 22 eurodéputés frontiste font
leur entrée au parlement
c'est un de moins par rapport à 2014
2020 ce sont les mêmes qu'on renouvelle
oui l'objectif de marine le pen est le
suivant consolider les villes acquises
en 2014 à l'époque le parti avait fait
une percée spectaculaire en remportant
une dizaine de villes dont béziers
fréjus ou encore hénin beaumont mais en
2020 c'est la douche froide le parti a
beau décrocher au perpignan avec louis
aliot il ne parvint pas à capitaliser
sur les bons chiffres de 2014 c'est même
le contraire le compteur reste bloqué à
dix villes et surtout il n'obtient que
840 sièges de conseillers municipaux
c'est quasiment deux fois moins qu'en
2014 ici on peut parler de dégringolade
de l'écouté du sénat et bien jusqu'en
2020 le parti comptait deux sénateurs
mais lors des dernières élections
sénatoriales seul stéphane ravier est
réélu dans les bouches du rhône le parti
ne compte donc plus qu'un seul sénateur
sur un des bancs de la haute assemblée
enfin cette année a été marquée par les
élections régionales et départementales
le parti misaient beaucoup sur ce
scrutin et les sondages le donnaient
favori dans certaines régions en
bourgogne franche comté dans les
pyrénées orientales ou encore en paca
autour de la candidature de thierry
mariani mais au final nouveau désaveu
pour le parti il ne décroche aucune
région n'y aucun département à
l'abstention joué en sa défaveur et on
se souvient de cette prise de parole
musclée de marine le pen qui appeler ses
électeurs à se ressaisir et à aller
voter pour le second tour mais le
sursaut d'un rappel et puis au niveau ge
n'a le rassemblement national a perdu un
tiers de ses élus oui il compte
désormais deux cent cinquante deux
conseillers régionaux et au niveau
départemental il perd plus de la moitié
de ses élus ils ne sont plus que 26 on
le voit donc à travers ces chiffres
l'implantation territoriale du
rassemblement national s'effrite d'année
en année il faut donc remobiliser les
troupes et les électeurs et présentée
hier à fréjus marine le pen a annoncé
qu'elle allait rapidement a multiplié
les déplacements sur le terrain dans les
départements merci mario merci marion
vigoureux dans ce sens public voilà une
chronique d'un journal de la rédaction
dans chacun de nos débats iris voyait
l'abstention c'est l'ennemi pas
seulement de marine le pen mais c'est
quand même un de ses ennemis c'est
clairement
l'abstention oui
je sais pas trop comment répondre à
cette question c'est un enjeu de sa
campagne disons que oui c'est un sujet
qui peut qui peut lui permettre de
mobiliser de weeds
on l'a vu on l'a vu aux dernières
élections aux dernières élections
locales c'est un très grand enjeu après
on sait que pour les pour les élections
présidentielles les commandes hier
l'adhésion à un parti n'est pas ne se
fait pas du tout de la même manière
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'avec ça avec
son affiche de campagne elle a vraiment
fait le choix de ne pas mettre avant le
rassemblement national pour pour jouer
ce renouvellement là
je sais pas si mes collègues veulent
compléter qu'est ce que vous en pensez
le sait ça explique aussi les chiffres
que marion il revient de donner serre
que dans les élections intermédiaires
l'abstention est très forte c'est
souvent pas le cas au moins le cas en
tout cas la présidentielle mais pourquoi
ça desservirait plus marine le pen ou
par exemple jean luc mélenchon
là j'ai l'impression que une fois
défalqué le pourcentage de l'abstention
qui est imputable à la pandémie il y a
eu quand même passé moi l'expression un
trou d'air j'ai des électeurs habituels
du rassemblement national qui se sont
dit bon le pouvoir c'est pour quand est
ce que c'est encore possible est ce que
ça vaut encore la peine c'est pour cinq
maillots main que marine le pen a tapé
du poing sur la table en quelque sorte à
l' annonce des résultats en dix ans et
bazars ressaisissez-vous malaisie
c'était un peu désespéré en tout cas on
pouvait l'apercevoir c'est un peu
désespérant fin c'était un peu désespéré
parce que c'est une vraie question de
fond qui se posent c'est à dire est ce
que
des gens qui pour certains ont milité
pendant 20 ans 30 ans et pour qui c'est
pas facile c'est pas la meilleure des
positions d'être le représentant local
du nul du r'n commence pas à se dire
mais finalement on n'y arrivera jamais
or ces gens veulent le pouvoir ils
veulent le pouvoir parce qu'ils sont les
représentants d'une famille politique
qui ne l'a jamais depuis le fit 75 ans
et qui attendent qu'ils adorent s'y fait
vraiment beaucoup merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
voilà c'est la fin de ce premier sens
public de la saison se retrouve dès
demain un débat d'actualité un débat
plus prospectif et la rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole qui est un
rendez vous demain l'invité dorian nancy
nice et laurent prête et race husky le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
retraites ce sera dans bonjour la france
salue à demain merci à toutes les
équipes de public sénat c'est un bonheur
de travailler avec vous
[Musique]